Veronica would you like to come with me
where to a place where I would teach you
things you like learning things don't
you what kind of things I would be
training you for a very important job
well can't gap the guy most people can't
handle
ad is the new waitress what's his
obsession with blondes it's just this
type what I miss
what do you guys do out there yonder
who's the beautiful bra got hooked up
for is this time man
[ __ ] taking what are you doing Saturday
night washing my hair
no you're doing that Friday night you
meet me here at 8 o'clock with clean
hair and red love steady well boys I'm
Veronica so are you ready for a game
depends on the game and I want you to
run Veronica and then what we aren't you
done
there is no one person more powerful
than the other only the one with the
most will is the strongest you're gonna
have to do this mission alone who and
enjoy this
Afghans five assisted are as flopped
under to start I did dub seeking so -
stop - [ __ ]